continúa la información de américa
latina y el mundo de france 24 y
hablamos ahora de economía estamos para
eso con danger hablando aunque nos va a
contar lo más importante de hoy danny la
bienvenida la economía argentina acumuló
ya tres años en recesión daniela liliana
buenas noches pues en 2020
tuvo una calidad del 10 por ciento este
de superador desempeño desde 2002 cuando
cayó díaz como 9% luego de la recordada
crisis económica del corralito además
profundizó la recesión que ya sufría el
país con contracciones del 2.5 y del 2,2
por ciento en los años anteriores
de hecho liliana 2020 no había empezado
bien el tejido productivo ya estaba
golpeado el consumo a la baja una
inflación al alza y una fuerte
inestabilidad financiera pues el
gobierno de alberto fernández ha tratado
de darle un giro a esta situación
primero renegoció una millonaria deuda
con acreedores privados y ahora negoció
con el fondo monetario internacional
también impulsó un impuesto único a la
riqueza y justo hoy anunció que no habrá
más subsidios eléctricos para unas
1900 industrias desde automotrices hasta
grandes espacios comerciales y
petroleras la idea y seguimos en brasil
porque avanza este país en una agenda
privatizadora de empresas el presidente
de ese país
jair bolsonaro radicó en el congreso un
proyecto para acelerar la privatización
de la empresa eléctrica eletrobrás y sus
filiales con la polémica todavía viva
por la reorganización de petrobras el
mandatario afirmó que su agenda de
privatización continúa a todo vapor y
ésta incluye alrededor de 100 empresas
el mecanismo en el caso de eletrobrás
sería emisión de acciones en la bolsa de
valores de sao paulo en un monto que
todavía no se sabe pero que si le
entregaría el control de la compañía al
sector privado pero esta no es la
primera vez que sucede esta
privatización ya se había hecho había
propuesto en 2016 pero no hubo consenso
político esta vez
bolsonaro recibió la promesa de los
presidentes de ambas cámaras de que su
iniciativa se va a acelerar
latinoamérica recibió créditos de china
en 2020 por primera vez en 15 años
esto lo dice en un estudio publicado por
el centro de estudios diálogo
interamericano de la universidad de
boston que sigue desde hace años las
inversiones de beijing en la región una
compilación de datos que hacen ellos
muestran cómodas de 2015 esos préstamos
de china a los gobiernos de américa
latina y el caribe se han venido
desacelerando y en 2020 llegaron a cero
esto debido entre otras cosas a las
dudas sobre la capacidad de pago de los
países por cuenta de la crisis de
acuerdo con el estudio venezuela era el
que disfrutaba de los créditos más altos
llevaba casi la mitad de esos préstamos
pero en los últimos cuatro años no ha
habido ninguna financiación desde
beijing hacia este país bueno y en pan
de viana de los precios de los
automóviles se dispararon en eeuu si
liliana el alza de los precios de los
automóviles superó con creces la
inflación del año pasado y como algunos
vieron inaccesible ese mercado de coches
nuevos se volcaron hacia el usado el
precio promedio de un vehículo en ese
país aumentó 6% en todo 2020
a un récord de más de 40 mil dólares
pero esto no es ni siquiera comparable
con el alza del 14% en los usados que
fue del 10 veces más que la tasa de
inflación y el precio promedio fue de
23.000 dólares según datos del portal
especializado edmunds la razón de esta
explosión de precio de liliana es
netamente económica muy pocos vehículos
disponibles para la venta durante la
pandemia debido a los cierres de
fábricas y demasiados compradores
aquellos que quieren evitar el
transporte público
angeline cuéntenos cómo están parados
los indicadores pues este miércoles
liliana se marca un nido bursátil hace
exactamente un año
los mercados comenzaron a vaticinar lo
que sucedería con el commit 19 que ese
día se desplomaron las bolsas y el
precio del petróleo hoy un año después
wall street' de sierra positivo en
europa las bolsas subieron tímidamente
tras conocerse que el pib alemán subió
más de lo previsto en el cuarto
trimestre y en américa latina la bolsa
de buenos aires puso fin a cuatro
jornadas bajas
en este parque claro que sí y la cifra
del día con que nos sorprende hoy 15 mil
400 millones de dólares en ayudas lanzó
hong kong este miércoles para recuperar
su economía en medio de un desempleo que
alcanza su mayor nivel en 16 años nadie
daniela por la información de colombia
ellos te dirán jazz por estar entre 224
continúen con más en france 24 punto com
[Música]